[Music]
well up until today my favorite story
out of the leftist dystopia of portland
happened a few years ago as reported by
andy noah at the time a professional
equity activist named lillian complained
about the racism she experienced at a
bakery called back to eden bakery and
lillian if you remember this story she
said that she had been refused service
by the two employees on staff and the
only logical explanation for this
refusal of course was that the employees
were vicious out in the open anti-black
races who just so happened to work in
downtown portland
after all why else would anyone
refuse service to a black woman i mean
why else would these two employees
actually tell the woman to leave without
allowing her to purchase any baked goods
that's what they said to her they said
leave
the owner of the bakery couldn't imagine
any other reason so she immediately
fired both of the transgressors threw
them under the bus publicly
and she also promised to hire black
women and members of the quote lgbtq poc
community to replace the two clansmen
that she had on her staff
further the the owner pledged to donate
10 percent of their sales to a charity
that bails criminals out of jail
and all of this was done but of course
it was not nearly enough to assuage the
hurt and pain and anguish suffered by
lillian
but it was a start anyway
oh um one note that might be relevant
here lillian came to the bakery after it
was closed
so she walked in six minutes after
closing and demanded to be served and
they refused on the basis that they were
no longer open
but that excuse wouldn't fly the bakery
should have checked with lillian
personally before deciding to close that
evening indeed they should have pulled
every black woman in the city
to see when they should close and open
and if any black woman desires a muffin
at any time of day or night
and is not able to procure it
immediately for low cost or no cost
then she is the victim of racism and
whatever bakery is nearest to her while
she is suffering this muffin deprivation
is guilty of committing a hate crime
against her
this just makes sense
i mean the bakery agreed that it made
sense
overall it was a great portland story my
favorite until this week anyway
libs of tick tock on her site libs of
tick tock dot com
has a story i think even better than a
bakery being accused of racism for not
serving a black woman after they already
closed
apparently uh this is what the story is
after after much fanfare and celebration
a lesbian bar opened this month in
portland called doc marie's
and there had surprisingly not been a
lesbian bar in portland so this was seen
as a significant and important event
an opening day was a huge success lines
around the block waiting to get in
a week later the place was closed
and the reason is pretty hilarious
reading now from the report it says doc
marie's is a lesbian bar that opened on
july 1st of this year with the hope of
bringing more inclusivity to the city of
portland
just one week after their grand opening
they were forced to shut down because of
complaints that the bar was not a safe
space the crowd on opening day was huge
one woman said that the line for entry
on voting day was wrapped around the
block with literally 200 lesbians
waiting to get in but the excitement
about a new progressive hangout
dissipated quickly within days doc
maurice found itself on the receiving
end of accusations of not being
inclusive enough for trans people and
people of color despite mass mandates
being lifted in portland patrons accused
the bar of not implementing enough
coveted safety measures patrons also
claimed that doc marie's had culturally
appropriate appropriative art on the
walls
that's just some of it it gets worse a
tick-tocker who goes by the handle
danger dallas and identifies herself as
a queer stripper who uses they them
pronouns followed the doc marie's case
closely as closely as you would expect
and provided a thorough outline of some
of the sins the lesbian bar committed in
just a week of being open
let's listen to that
payroll systems that are not paying
people correctly discrepancies in
salaries dirty water leaking onto the
floor um and the owner enabling racist
behavior
so the the real reason why dog marie's
is closed is because when the workers
brought these concerns to the ownership
the next day after opening day the
ownership did not meet the concerns with
any sort of plan of action and the
unsatisfactory response caused the
managers to quit their jobs immediately
the workers collective goes on to assure
us that protecting black and brown lgbtq
plus folks in building an acti actively
anti-racist space is their top priority
um that they are committed to ongoing
racial bias training and will continue
to educate ourselves in order to
actively foster a safe environment while
upholding a zero policy towards racism
so we take from that that the entire
staff made a list of demands
and because those demands were not met
right on the spot
they all quit
a day after the place opened
back to the libs of tick-tock report it
says employees of doc marie's created an
instagram page to echo these concerns
they claim that the owners weren't
proactive enough in creating a safe
space and accused the owners of racism
the employees also demanded that the bar
host free opportunities for education
for the community eventually the
employees demanded the owners relinquish
ownership of the bar and hand the
business over to them
this all happened in like a day of being
open i have to remind you the owners
were given a 24-hour deadline to adhere
to the ludicrous demands just five days
after opening the bar announced that
july 6 they had to close temporarily in
order to address the cries from the woke
mob for a safe and inclusive space
and now the bar is closed with no
immediate plans to reopen they say only
that they are working on a plan to
become proud and inclusive
meanwhile their employees or former
employees i guess
still insist that the the business they
chose to work for
committed an unforgivable violation
by being a business
they demanded the business should not be
a business at all it should be it should
have no ownership
it should provide free services
and its primary goal should be racial
equity
now as a greedy capitalist i would have
thought that a business's primary goal
is to turn a profit
so that it remains in business
but that's just not the way things are
done in portland
and the problem only compounds for doc
marines because
they're closed you know they closed so
as to stop inflicting whatever
unspecified trauma on the black and
trans community
but as the bakery learned a few years
ago
you're also inflicting trauma by being
closed
see this is the trouble with being a
black or trans person in portland
literally no matter what anyone else
does they are always victimizing you
and the bigger problem for being not
black or trans in portland is that
literally no matter what you do you're
always victimizing someone in one of
those groups
now i of course am not at all interested
in uh defending the portland lesbian bar
from the woke mob i am interested
instead in standing on the sidelines and
uh just snickering about the whole thing
because it's funny and also in observing
and studying this self-cannibalizing
victimhood orgy
to see what we can learn from it and as
far as i can tell the big and also kind
of encouraging takeaway
is that leftism is inherently weak and
vulnerable it has institutional power
and so it controls the culture but
considered on its own
we see that it's prone to dissension
mutiny paralysis
this is just one example of the left
eating itself every day provides new
ones and this happens because leftism is
a fundamentally self-focused
self-obsessed ideology it discourages
any real unity any real rallying around
a central cause because everyone's
central cause is themselves all
alliances are formed only temporarily
for as long as each person individually
feels served by it
nobody is looking out towards anything
transcendent anything beyond themselves
it's hard for them to march in the same
direction together for very long because
they're all staring not ahead but back
into themselves
into their egos
up their own asses basically
the only universal code they recognize
is the ever fluctuating ever changing
ever more complicated victimhood
hierarchy a system that breeds
competition as each group vises for
ultimate victim status
and each individual within each group
competes not only with the other groups
but with members of their own group
intersectional splinter factions are
constantly formed as people look to
marginalize themselves more and more
because in their inverted upside down
world to be on the margins is to be in
power
it is fortunate for the left tragic for
the rest of us that this final plunge
into self-defeating self-cannibalizing
madness happened after they'd already
gained control of every institution if
it had happened before they never would
have had this success
this is what creates the ironic
situation where the far left runs
the most powerful cultural institutions
in the country
but they can't even manage to keep a
lesbian bar in portland open for more
than a week
and still even with their institutional
power
this madness makes them vulnerable
it makes them beatable
and sometimes
it even makes them very funny to watch
and so though i am not the one who
decided to cancel them that is
nonetheless why doc marie's the lesbian
bar in portland
is today cancelled
well before you go uh hit the subscribe
button and ring the bell and while
you're at it if you want to go watch or
listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe you can also
catch my show on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated